we have Scott squared joining me now is
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott and
Florida Senator Rick Scott all right um
let's start with Congressman Congressman
I'm losing it Senator Rick Scott look
you have Christen Cinema out there today
um really trying to push back on the
criticisms many of them launched on the
Ingram angle against this bill who that
nobody can see she said well even
without the the concern about the 5,000
migrants a day that can come and before
the trigger they're going to have to
have 90 days to show that they meet the
Asylum standard once they're here what
happens to them in that 90 days Senator
well they're all they're coming in
they'll probably get work permits you
never know think about this this this
can't be a good deal other otherwise
they show it to us where's the text why
can't they put out the text and
McConnell had said we cannot tie border
security to Ukraine a so we got a
lawless Administration Biden's not going
to comply with anything so if we don't
tie it to something he wants nothing's
going to happen he'll just violate the
law just like he's been like he's done
and we don't need a bill cuz Trump
secured the Border without a new bill
well they know that they're lying to the
American people they know Senator Scott
absolutely from South Carolina that we
don't need a bill we need a president
who actually wants a border Absolut we
were better off with trump our border
was Secure under President trump it is
wide open unsafe insecure under Joe
Biden here's the worst of it last month
Laura just last month as many people
crossed our border illegally as we're
born in America as many people crossed
our border illegally 10,000 a day as
we're born in our country 10,000 a day
we're having as many illegal immigrants
cross our border as we are legally born
Americans This invasion is insane we
need four more years of Donald Trump to
secure our border he's done it once he
will do it again let's get it started we
need massive deportation of do we not we
need people like it cost a lot no it
cost a lot more to keep 10 million
people here who shouldn't be here we got
to secure the border and if you're not
here legally go home you've got you've
got to go home and we can't we can't
just continue to open the border and by
the way we can't pass a bill that
possibly would make it harder for Trump
to do his job well you know that's what
the language is going to be this is how
it's always written and it was written
by Schumer's people I understand that's
been it's been written for four months
why did they refuse to share the text of
the bill anything about the bill or meet
with the speaker of the house why did
they not do that be well first off they
don't care about the house I mean they
want to try to cram this down this I've
been up here five years here's how it
works since Biden took office Schumer
and McConnell get together they decide a
bill they don't give us any time to
review it right they give it to us and
expect us to vote on that day and if you
don't vote for it then you don't care
about that issue no Amendment votes
nothing they just try to cram 48 hours
to read uh 1,200 Pages look at the omnus
it was uh three times the size of the
Bible 1.7 tril they wanted to vote on it
that day when they gave it to us at 1:30
in the morning this is simple remember
Obamacare you got to pass the bill to
know what's in it not again every single
Republican should be absolutely
positively unequivocally a no because
you can't read something you don't have
well Mitch McConnell is now saying he
wants to separate Ukraine and the Border
um basically he said that today but but
even even we have the sound bite let's
play it
okay had a lot of discussion obviously
about the board around here but it's
important to focus on the other
rationale for the supplemental hopefully
we can work this border issue out in a
way that's satisfactory but there's
bipartisan support here in the senate
for both Israel and
Ukraine well that's what it's really
about is it not I mean money for Ukraine
but we shouldn't be P we have a majority
in the house why are we passing things
so we know the house won't pass because
it's a sham they know it's not going to
pass I really believe that well there
there's no doubt that if won't pass
number one number two why would we be
more concerned about securing Ukraine's
border than America's border if there's
no America the city on the hill dies the
whole world suffers we have to secure
our own border protect our own people
and create an economy that the world
Marvels at Senator Scott uh President
Biden's going to East Palestine Ohio
finally a year after that train
derailment I mean he's looking at the
polls that I discussed in the angle is
he not he's in deep deep we didn't even
get into Ohio I think he's down what 12
points in Ohio you can't beat Trump the
biggest issue is the Border he secured
the Border next issue is the economy we
had a great economy the third issue is
we don't want to be a war all over the
world look at the world it's a disaster
right now all because this is Biden's
plan it's not working Laura the mayor of
East Palestine said Joe Biden can come
in January 2025 when he's no longer
president well I can say senator Scott
um
the attempt to bail out Joe Biden by the
plutocrats and a lot of these people you
know big money donors and there're maybe
friends of yours friends of mine
shoveling money to Nikki Haley um to
keep this shade going and she's just
trying to Savage Trump every stop she
gets I don't believe President Trump
should even mention her name going
forward I wouldn't even talk about her
no he's going to win he's way ahead
there's it's not even close he's got
he's got he did this you can't beat him
he did this he's going to he's easily
going to win the prize I don't know why
she stay in the race but then he's going
to easily win the president the
presidency because he has a plan he did
it Biden Biden is a disaster everything
he's done is a disaster Trump's going to
win big we're doing a town hall on
February 20th with President Trump in um
South Carolina my home and you're in
your home state am I invited of course
you're invited um so what's going to
happen in South Carolina that's you know
is that her waterl finally or well
listen it's simple it's my state and I
love I love South Carolina God bless the
great state of South Carolina Trump by
25 in her home state listen if you
secure the Border you protect Social
Security she suggested that you should
means test Social Security he our man
Trump will protect our seniors on Social
Security she said just the 20 people in
their 20s she kind of backed away from
that right if you start anywhere you
start correting everybody on the record
there every single senior citizen wants
to be secure in the retirement Trump
does that we want to be safe in our
homes we had Law and Order we want a
Biden economy h no way in the world do
we want a Biden economy we want Trump
tax cuts opportunity zones and more
opportunities for every American um
Senators Scott thank you both for being
with us great to see you you should you
should have been the house uh I'm
putting you back in the house I don't
know why Senate Majority Leader soon I
hope thank you for joining us from
another mother this is awesome exactly
great to see you both thanks so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else